hi everyone in this short video one of
our Affiliated locksmiths is going to
show you how he's coding a new Dodge key
fub uh this is how it's actually done on
site in case you lost all your keys or
just want to have a spare set this is a
necessary procedures the procedure that
requires a spatial machine for all uh
Dodge key fobs and transponder Keys uh
if you have any questions please comment
below and we will answer thanks for
watching
good morning everybody we're programming
a new key today for 2013 Dodge Durango
it's a push to start and also the fob I
mean this is a fob insert so this button
pops
out and we're going to put the key in
there for programming
purposes use our program here we're
going to go to uh Dodge
obviously we're going to go to the
Durango North
America 10 to13 we're going to program
the fabbi key first the manual key
inserts this is a Dodge model Chrysler
Jeep we have to obtain a pin code so we
can uh read it from the
vehicle and that PIN code needs to be
inserted when you try to program the key
or else it will not work so there's our
pin
code key
learning there are four current keys in
this
vehicle this will be number
five over the years people get a lot of
keys made different owners so the key
successfully learned we do not want to
learn the next key now we want to
synchronize a smart
key so we inserted the key into the slot
like it's fing us and now it's learning
to push to start
feature so this feature it's called a
peps it allows you to start the car by
pushing a button as long as the fob is
in the
vehicle that's it job is complete button
work we are going to take the push to
start button and pop it back
into the slot here we'll put our foot on
the
brake and there you
go one more
[Music]
time up and running buttons work we're
good to go thanks for watching guys 2013
Dodge
Durango for